inaugurations are how presidents try to
showcase the future
a swirl of parades and parties
crowds watching politics through a
technicolor lens
[Applause]
but not this time it's troops
and barriers not
fanfare washington feels like a fortress
right now there's a huge security
perimeter
in place and check points everywhere you
look it's really difficult to get around
it feels like a city preparing for the
worst and the fbi director has warned
state and local officials to be on high
alert
the national more usually packed might
not even open to the public
a riot and a pandemic has put everyone
on edge and there's a vast
search for suspects after last week's
siege
some surprises former olympic
swimmer clete keller has been charged
after people said they spotted him
wearing a team jacket
inside the capitol
kevin seyfried captured carrying a
confederate flag
handed himself in to police in delaware
today
some are being tracked down by super
sleuths in the suburbs
so this is a screenshot from a telegram
group
that was recently de-platformed and who
just came back
and it says january 20th stoked the
boomers flame encouraged armed struggle
right immediately beneath that we see
should politicians
shoot politicians tara says she's
sharing information about explosive
devices and imminent
infrastructure attacks with law
enforcement
how would you characterize the
individuals
that you're seeing talking about these
events
now we're seeing that the person that
you pass in the street could likely be a
domestic terrorist
and to me that's frightening i believe
that their the the the momentum
that we saw at the sixth in our capital
will be amplified for the 20th of
january
i'm fearful that there will be using
improvised
devices that can be easily concealed
no one can afford to drop the ball in
this fractious handover of power
the removal vans are in at the white
house but the worry is that the anger
donald trump inspired
could be here to stay cordelia lynch sky
news
washington